Daniel: All right.
Welcome, Mahault.
This will be the final of the
presentation sessions in the symposium.
This is Mahault Albarracin with the
presentation “Shared protentions in
active inference.”
So, thank you, Mahault, to you.
And you're the first to join with an AI
Steward/Guardian.
Mahault: Awesome.
Shall I share my screen?
Daniel: Yes.
Mahault: Let's do.
Just a second.
I'm looking for a window.
I think this will do.
Okay, so can you see the screen?
Daniel: Yes.
Looks good.
Thank you.
Mahault: Awesome.
So, unfortunately, I imagine that you are
seeing the entire screen and not just the
presentation.
I apologize about that.
Daniel: I got it.
It's cropped.
I got it.
Mahault: Okay, wonderful.
Thank you.
All right, so welcome to the presentation
on Shared Potential under Active
Inference.
We're going to cover a lot of topics.
Shall I introduce myself a little bit, or
have you already done that?
Awesome.
So, my name is Mawal Bahasa.
I'm a PhD student in cognitive computing.
.
I work in active inference in the
interaction between social sciences,
philosophy, consciousness, science, and
artificial intelligence.
We're going to start a presentation on
potential and active inference.
So I'm going to define a lot of terms.
It's going to deal into philosophy, terms
that are very deep.
And so let's get started.
If you will just give me one small second.
.
And we're back.
So, shared potential is a term derived
from phenomenology, and it refers to the
shared anticipation of future events
among a group of individuals.
This philosophical study of experience
and consciousness becomes particularly
interesting when we consider it in the
context of active inference.
When we combine these two concepts, we
get a powerful tool for understanding how
groups of individuals can coordinate
their actions and work towards a common
goal.
This is the main focus of the discussion
today.
So imagine a group of people planning a
trip.
They all share a common goal to have a
successful and enjoyable trip.
This shared goal forms the basis of their
shared potential.
They all anticipate future events related
to the trip, such as booking tickets,
packing their bags, and visiting various
attractions.
As they start to take actions towards
their goal, they're also engaging in
active inference.
They're making predictions about what
will happen next and then adjusting these
predictions based on what actually
happens.
So, for example, they might predict that
a certain flight will be the cheapest
based on their past experiences.
But when they actually check the prices,
they find that another flight is cheaper.
.
So they adjust their prediction and book
the other flight.
This constant cycle of prediction and
adjustment, guided by their shared
potential, helps the group coordinate
their actions and make their trip a
success.
So we're going to delve deeper into the
concepts and explore the role of past
experiences known as retentions in
shaping our current knowledge and future
predictions.
Let's explain first the concept of
retentions.
Retention is a key component of time
consciousness that retains the past
trajectory of a temporal object.
It's the preservation of the content of a
now past hyletic datum in our present
consciousness.
A highletic datum refers to the raw,
uninterpreted sensations that arise in
our consciousness.
When we retain these data, we are
essentially keeping a record of past
sensations and experiences that can
inform our present and our future actions.
.
In active inference, we can formalize
retention by thinking of moments as
binning of states which are bound to a
hierarchical state.
This way, retention is seen as the
bidding which becomes the current state,
informing the next expected state.
To further connect retention with active
inference, we can consider the way in
which retention plays a role in updating
an agent's belief and generative model.
The past experiences influence the
current expectations and actions, thus
shaping the agent's understanding of the
world and the future.
So let's consider a practical example to
illustrate this concept.
If you had a good experience at a
particular restaurant, you might choose
to go there again in the future.
Your past experience influences your
future decision.
In hostile temporal phenomenology, we
would think about much shorter timescale.
.
But if we extend this concept, we can see
a much larger structure wherein the
retention is simply the past state.
It's like having a mental note that says
this place is good.
And this is how an example of retention
works in your everyday life.
They're not merely representation or
memories, but presentations of a
temporarily extended present which
distinguishes them from recollections.
This involves the presentation of some
already constituted content in conscious
experience.
Retentions also play a crucial role in
mapping past knowledge onto current
beliefs, contributing to the development
of shared narratives or goals that we
will delve into in the rest of the
presentation.
They can be former now points and the
current awareness of the past and far.
Sedimented retentions can be engraved in
scripts or deep temporal priors or more
fluid deontic cues.
This phenomenon corresponds to a specific
application of message passing between
agents in the present moment and in the
sensorium.
Retentions and protensions may also
emerge jointly within a group, forming a
collective understanding that transcends
individual perspectives.
Protensions, as we saw, refer to the
anticipation of future events based on
past experiences and current knowledge.
It's thus forward looking.
It's the forward looking counterpart to
retention which is backward looking.
Retention is the anticipation of future
trajectories of a temporal object.
It's the process of looking ahead,
predicting what's to come based on what
has been and what currently is.
So in active inference, it could be
formalized by considering the future
states that are expected based on the
current state and past states.
Protension is thus the anticipation
guiding the next action.
We can consider the way in which
protension plays a role in updating an
agent's beliefs and generative models
influencing the actions and thus shaping
the agent's understanding of the world
and the future.
So for instance, if you see Dark Cloud in
the sky, you might anticipate that it's
going to rain and decide to carry an
umbrella.
This anticipation of future events is
potential.
It's also going to determine whether or
not you're wet when you go outside and
therefore whether or not you expect to be
wet.
Your brain is constantly making
predictions about what's going to happen
next.
So let's put this in the context of
temporal flow which ties together those
concepts of primal impressions and we
will see retention and protention.
Temporal flow is the structure that
represents the continuous progression of
time from the past through the present
and into the future.
Agents are constantly revising their
generative models and they do this by
integrating the observations which we
could refer to here as primal impressions.
.
This updating process is a balancing act
between maintaining the predictive
density of the agent's current beliefs
and adapting to new information.
Retentions and pretensions structure time
for a given agent creating a framework
that shapes their perception and
anticipation.
Different agents or systems will exhibit
varying qualities and quantities of
retention and potential which resembles
something like Mike Levin's concept of
cognitive light codes.
So given the presence of retention we can
anticipate a protentional horizon not
merely as an arbitrary expectation.
Are thus the point at which agents
beliefs about the world are updated to
match their current observations which
leads to a more accurate understanding of
the environment and allows for more
effective goal directed behavior.
Primal impressions are the fulfillment of
a potential which is the time bound nexus
of perception and existence.
It is the resolved probability that
redefines the local gradient.
It's in primal impression that reality
collapses.
The primal impression is thus modeled as
the essential Bayesian cognitive moment.
It is the juxtaposition of prior beliefs
or retention with ongoing sensory
information in an unfolding future
oriented present or retention.
So now we have a description of temporal
thickness from feminine ominnology which
is compatible with generative modeling
and active inference agents for hospital.
.
This flow of conscious experience is
primarily made up of sensations that well
up in a raw uninterpreted form that we
called earlier hyletic data.
So this data is the now phase of a
temporal object.
It is formatted according to the identic
or cognitive laws of consciousness.
This is specifically relative to inner
time.
We can understand how temporal flow
structures how agents are able to make
choices, act to self evidence, connect
the passive structure with the active
component of decision making or goal
pursuit.
Individuals have drives and teleology
insofar as they have preferences.
These preferences are protented goals
reached towards by what we would call
potentially the fiat wherein the fiat
constitutes the will to act towards a
desire.
So the fulfillment of a pretension by
fiat drives the agent towards a teleology
across a trail set in a retentional
extension.
More information is amassed.
So the longer your retention, more
information can be caught in a moment.
As individuals amass enough information
they can then find a structure to the
information which becomes a map rather
than a territory and is computationally
more efficient than the sum of all the
information amassed.
This new state of information may lead
individuals closer to a shared goal.
The information amassed turns into an
emergent whole of the retention, which
grabs focus at the present moment because
it seems to bring signals to the model
that the potential goal is closer and is
computationally simpler to retain.
So sharing of retentions and potentials
among group members in a social context
can facilitate coordination and the
achievement of a shared goal.
By aligning their beliefs about the past
or retentions and expectations about the
future or potentials, group members can
better predict each other's actions and
intentions.
This allows them to work together more
effectively.
In some cases, group members may have
retentions and potentials that align
naturally due to common experiences or
understanding.
Even without active communication,
however, group members often actively
communicate their retentions and
protensions, aligning their beliefs and
expectations through dialogue and
interaction, thereby enhancing their
ability to predict each other's actions
and intentions.
Retentions and protensions may also
emerge jointly within the group, not
confined to any individual agents, unvelt
forming a collective understanding that
transcends individual perspectives.
This complex interplay of individual and
collective dynamics can be explored
further in hierarchical generative models
encompassing resonant, cognitive models,
communication and even joint emergence.
The structure of time consciousness
encapsulated in retention and protension
thus plays a significant role in the
emergence of shared potentials.
As agents retain and process similar
elements from their environment, they can
cocompute shared potentials by mapping
each other's cognitive pathways and
building upon one another's trails.
This process is formalized by Bayesian
updating the relationship between the
topology of protensions and the
expectation gradient, as well as the role
of retention in mapping past knowledge on
the current beliefs plays a role in
development of shared narratives and
goals.
We can use this to get a deeper insight
into the processes that drive the
emergence of collective behavior and the
development of shared understanding among
agents.
There is no better way to do it than
using active inference by extending
generative models of individual agents to
account for the beliefs and goals of
other agents.
This is akin to theory of mind.
It enables them to anticipate and adapt
to the actions of their peers by
offloading to the group.
So we discussed a little bit's earlier
shared goals.
Potential goals are future oriented
objectives that individuals or groups
strive to achieve.
They're not just mere desires, but they'
're actively pursued through the act of
will that we called earlier fiat.
The fulfillment of a pretension drives
the agent towards a teleology that trail
set.
We discussed the fulfillment of a
prediction entails less surprise and
therefore the agent self evidences.
By seeking to accurately predict their
surroundings, agents select a series of
actions or policies which generate
transitions between states that produce
expected observations.
So through the choice of policy, an
individual can reach their potented goal
by minimizing the expected free energy
that a given policy affords them.
This seems pretty central and simple in
terms of active inference.
So farther potentials are represented by
the policies of longer time death.
In a hierarchical model, this corresponds
to a policy tied to a higher level action
in a slower timescale.
The choice of policies driven by the
expected free energy of that higher order
policy or the entire multiscale
generative model is based on the agent's
preferences, allowing an agent to conduct
gold directed behaviors across temporal
scales.
So this is where we can cash out Jeff
Yoshimi's trail sets where agents
assimilate actions into the anticipated
continuity of objects in their
surrounding world.
This simulation ensures a smoother
understanding of the environment and
helps agents adapt effectively.
Near potentials act as the near present
contextual.
Proximity and the far pretensions rely on
passive synthesis of deontic cues which
are sedimented retentions in the
environment.
The preferences of the agents aligned by
policies correspond to attracting sets
which in the sociocognitive setting can
be instantiated as narratives.
Having shared narrative is a necessary
aspect of any exchange between artifacts,
people, institutions that have some kind
of attracting set generalized synchrony
which we will discuss a little bit later
as well.
So a team working on a project has a
potential goal to complete the project
successfully.
The shared narrative might be the project
plan that guides their actions.
It's like everyone in the team has a
shared story about what they're trying to
achieve and how they're going to do it.
The relationship between current states
and future observations is captured
within the B matrix transitions.
This matrix represents the probability of
transitioning to a new state based on the
current state.
So the B matrix transition and the A
matrix is utilized to determine which new
observations is most likely to occur
given the current state and potential
transitions.
In the Cerulean framework, the
expectation gradient structure plays a
crucial role in defining the depth and
fulfillment of pretensions.
This structure represents the varying
degrees of certainty and confidence
agents have in their predictions about
future states.
The topology thus and the arrangements is
interrelation.
Sorry.
There is an interrelation between the
potentials or the arrangements of future
expectations which is proportional to the
expectation gradient.
The higher the gradient, the more
detailed and accurate the potentials are
likely to be.
The potential horizon represents thus the
static states of the expected futures of
the temporal object while the
continuation horizon is the amalgamated
trail of the temporal object.
Potential and continuation horizons are
carried in protensions while the imminent
horizon consists of the primal
impressions.
So agents can coordinate through
coconstruction where agents or
individuals interact and collaborate to
build this shared understanding and
shared goals.
This process is deeply interconnected
within a complex web where agents
typically coexist with other agents or
subjects forming a collective often
referred to as multiagent groups, swarm
ensembles or Samblage.
By aligning their beliefs to the signal
found within their niche they can better
adapt to the environment and develop a
shared understanding of their
surroundings.
Sharing information with other agents is
beneficial as it allows them to trust one
another and pool their resources.
This collaborative approach is preferable
to a conflict driven scenario in which
every other agent is perceived as a
potential source of risk and surprising.
By sharing information agents could
collectively construct a more accurate
representation of their environment
leading to more effective decision making
and action.
Through these interactions, shared
narratives and goals can emerge from a
coconstruction of the world and each
agent's generative model.
So these narratives and goals are the
result of dynamic process that in fact
can be mathematically modeled through the
equations that we introduce in the paper
that this presentation is based on but
that I will present a little bit later.
They capture the process of mutual
learning where agents adapt their
generative model based on the information
gathered from their interactions with
others.
Agents may start off with slightly or
greatly divergent generative model.
So in order to minimize surprise there
will be a natural alignment within a
group as agents adapt to the evolving
dynamics of their environment and social
contexts.
For example, again, consider this team
working on the project.
Even if you have your own understanding
of the model or of the project you'll
interact and share information and learn
from each other and then adapt the model.
.
Over time, you'll develop a shared
understanding of the project and a shared
goal for its completion.
This is an instance of coconstruction.
It's like building a house together where
everyone contributes to the final
structure.
The emergence of shared narratives and
the learning and recognition of them may
be made more efficient through certain
mechanisms such as language.
In an experiment illustrated in a paper
that Karl Rozan two agents share the same
sensorium ask each other's questions.
I think it's a paper on 20 questions and
Emma Holmes with a shared narrative
entailing a common language.
This illustrates the marked efficiency
and the minimization of free energy
simply by having a shared language, a
common ground.
So shared potentials are common future
anticipations or goals that emerge among
groups of individuals through
coconstruction.
It allows them to better anticipate each
other's actions and intentions and work
towards a common goal.
It's strongly tied to the conscious
efforts of individuals to work towards
that goal and to effectively create an
organizational structures where we're
engaged in a conversation in an exchange
assuming that this exchange is meant to
align our generative models.
So think of for instance, a football team.
.
Again, they have a shared potential to
win the match.
They anticipate each other's moves and
adapt their strategies based on the
ongoing game.
Everyone in the team has a shared vision
of victory and they're constantly
adjusting their actions to make it happen.
.
So individuals infer each other's mental
states by observing cues which they can
attribute to hidden causes.
They use their own model or models that
they have learned to recognize about
others.
This process is known as generalized
synchrony entailing mutual predictability,
, and can be interpreted as a collective
minimization of free energy.
In a group setting, individuals create
cues in the world that direct other
agents attentions towards the same
signals.
Their models of the world align by
sharing similar goals and similar
environments and by reinforcing patterns
of sampling reality.
So we could try to represent this through
polynomials and morphisms.
Each agent's interaction with the
environment corresponds to a morphism,
and the collective interaction of all
agents can be represented as a polynomial.
.
So if a polynomial p is defined, morphism
between two polynomials, p and q,
consists of a pair of functions, f and g,
such that f maps p of one to q of one and
g maps P of I to q of the quantity one.
This morphism must satisfy the
commutative requirements, meaning that
the following diagram commutes p of I
maps to q of the quantity I and p of one
maps to q of one.
So we could see how we could create a
framework to further explore the
cooperative and competitive dynamics
among agents.
For multiple agents indexed by I with
boundaries p and share environment
boundary q, their interaction can be
represented by a morphism of polynomials,
which allows us to understand the shared
potential in multiagent systems and
provides a foundation for further
exploration of cooperative dynamics.
We allow each agent to predict not only
its own behavior, but also the behavior
of its companions and the environment's
response to their actions.
So the dynamics of shared predictions are
really useful here and can be properly
cashed out mathematically through
recursive cognition and prediction on the
shared environment of the agent's actions
and response to each other's actions.
We can use sheep's theoretic and topos
theoretical approaches to understand
multi agent systems.
A multi agent system is a system where
multiple individuals or entities interact.
.
So for example, a traffic system can be
considered a multi agent system where
different vehicles interact.
A topos is a category that has both
spatial and logical structure, allowing
for the expression of logical
propositions and deductions within it.
So we can use these approaches to
construct a coherent understanding of the
world from the perspective of multiple
agents.
The internal universe of agents, which
can be seen as mathematical objects
containing beliefs, perceptions and
predictions of individual agents, are
represented using topoi.
These internal universes provide a
foundation for understanding and
representing the complex interactions and
shared understanding among multiple
agents in this dynamic environment.
We try to construct a consensus topos by
patching together the internal universes
or topoi of multiple agents.
And the idea is to use the sheep
theoretic and topos theoretic structures
to build a shared understanding.
So we can thus derive the synchronization
of goal oriented actions among agents
over time and leverage mathematical
insights for category theory and
generalized generative models.
This connection is the mechanism through
which the group synchronizes over time
and ultimately achieves their objective.
Agents within the system might possess
varying levels of certainty in achieving
the objective.
Some may choose to expend less energy,
temporarily decelerating their progress
towards the desired outcome.
This variation in certainty and approach
leads to the emergence of different roles
within a group, with some agents focusing
on computational tasks while other
monitor outcomes or engage in different
actions themselves.
The nested and distributed structure of
generative models in active inference
allows for the integration of both short
term and long term goals.
Agents with similar compatible
preferences can coordinate their actions
by aligning their policies and working
towards common narratives.
So this alignment reduces the overall
expected free energy of their joint
actions, increasing the likelihood of
achieving shared goals and facilitating
the sharing of goals and expectation
among group members.
They can learn, which allows them to
learn essential role in shaping agents
preferences and strategies.
Over time, agents can gather new
experiences and update their generative
model.
They refine their preferences and methods
for achieving goals.
They can influence the formation and
modification of shared narratives by
having different perspective over
different parts of a goal.
Here, the concept of generalized
synchrony is manifested when all agents
have learned compatible or harmonized
aspects of the overall generative model.
The synchronization is rooted in the
retentional and potential dynamics of
agents and can be more accurately
described using mathematical models.
So, in conclusion, we tried to shed light
on the concept of shared potential goals
and multiagent systems.
We've emphasized the importance of
understanding this concept as it plays a
crucial role in the coordination
synchronization of agents actions and
intentions.
We in the future continuously highlight
the role of cues in the environment and
how they can be simple like marks on the
road or more complex like symbols and
language.
The queues become carriers of passive
synthesis, far pretensions and far
retention, and become ways to minimize
free energy as they minimize the amount
of any individual has to compute.
It also allows us to delve into the
concept of other evidencing in which the
environment is in effect the self and
others must learn to navigate in terms of
others and self.
We've provided mathematical models to an
equations to analyze dynamics of shared
potentials more accurately.
In terms of category theory, we've
explored the dynamics of shared
retentions and potentials in hierarchical
generative models which reflect the
complex interplay of individual and
collective dynamics.
We've encapsulated the structure of time
consciousness and how this allows agents
to co compute shared potentials by
mapping each other's cognitive pathways.
So our approach basically begins an
examination of hospital temporal
phenomenology integrated with a
hierarchical active inference model,
polynomial morphisms and home polynomials.
.
This enables recursive cognition and
prediction of not only an agent's actions,
, but also the environment's response to
these actions.
So I think this comes to the end, Daniel.
.
I think I'm literally at 30 minutes.
Daniel: Thank you, impeccable.
Thank you, Mahault it.
Yeah, great presentation.
Awesome topic.
So thank you for joining and looking
forward to seeing how the work continues
to develop.